fresh off a much-needed win for his
Dodgers last night is Dave Roberts how
are you Dave hey what's happenin I'm
doing well and you said it a much-needed
win and in good fashion I'm a lot better
than it was a couple days ago now it's
interesting I mentioned this to Alex
Cora the other day when he was on the
show on Monday that you guys aren't
called coaches for a reason you're
called managers for a reason because you
must manage not only the team but the
talent and the meant the mentality of
your players and I can only imagine the
manner in which you guys were losing
games with the kenley jansen going down
to injury and being on the disabled list
with several blown leads go-ahead runs
being scored against you in the ninth
inning four times how do you manage a
situation like that in your Clubhouse
yeah that's well phrased and it is
managing it and it is the psyches of the
guys and just you know a loss a
major-league loss is tough and no one
likes to lose but when you're losing
games in the eighth and ninth inning
that makes it a lot tougher obviously it
just to keep guys positive and coming in
fresh and for me it's one of those
things that in our Clubhouse the culture
we have rich that there's no blaming
everyone and we were in it together
and yesterday guys picked each other up
and the young kid Kayla Berg has been
really good for us and had a tough one
last night but those ice for us to come
through but you look around the guys I
love our guys I love the clubhouse
and I still feel that pesky well I mean
you're only a game and a half out and
there's 40 games to go so I mean you're
right there it's a three-team race
essentially although the Giants are
coming on strong so when you say keep it
positive I mean how do you do that you
look for anybody with their heads
hanging or of fingers pointing I mean
how do you accomplish that fact I think
just come in fresh you know you know you
look at some of the games that we lost
in front of what four or five games get
and you look at eight innings of each
game play pretty good baseball we really
have swung the bats well but the
starting pitches they're really good and
the pen by and large those guys that
really pissed our tails off and
just losing games lady and one bad
inning so I think that for us myself the
coach we have guys like Justin Turner
also really helps the mood and Clayton
Kershaw's been fantastic and such a pro
and I was also like I said rich when you
know that the talent is in the room
ultimately we're going to fizzle and
what have you learned about Machado
having them in front of you now Dave
that you perhaps didn't know well one
thing is he looks really good in a Dodge
[Applause]
but you know what I think that started
off well and the skill set obviously is
is ridiculous cooled off a little bit
but getting back home I think he's
really swinging the bat well now and
just the versatility to be able to put
him at third base and play ridiculous
defense at third base and then play plan
is short and you saw the other night the
fair interplay falls to his right the
arm strength things like that so he's
all in and so you look at Machado who we
just acquired a few weeks ago but just
kind of where he's at right now the way
he's simply at the clubhouse
it's like he's been a Dodger all year
and have you had a conversation with
Corey Seager about Machado being
acquired and we have not I have not I've
seen Corey just finish his hip surgery
so he's back in town doing rehab but as
far as the conversation regarding many
outside of it's good to have him and
he's gonna help us win a championship
this year that's about it but is he you
think he might be concerned about the
future that that Machado might stick
around and Seger might have to move or
or Turner or the future as that been I
don't think and I know Corey pretty well
so I don't think that he gets too far
ahead of thing and and you know
obviously managed a great player but the
office uses a long ways away and he's
free so he can kind of do what he
chooses you know and pick where he wants
to so when that happens we'll adjust but
if it's and when it happens but I think
right now Corey's just from the first
teammates and how is Janssen how is he
Kenley is in a good place I know that
there's a cardiologist appointment on
the 20th and hopefully we get the green
light from there but as far as spirits
and yesterday red she's doing a
simulated game to some guys so the arms
trying to keep that going he's in great
shape working out and stuff like that he
just couldn't take swings yesterday off
of them because potential for a ball
about it ball hitting them but hopefully
we can get them get them going show so
it's possible he won't be gone a month
you think it is certainly certainly and
I'm holding out hope the organization is
Kenley is but ultimately it's Doc
decision Dave Roberts Dodgers manager
here on the Rich Eisen show now I know
you've got your own shop
you have your own team you have your own
issues and then you were out on the
field but I don't know if you did see
what happened in Atlanta last night
between Jose urania and Ronald Acuna jr.
Dave did you see that I did Richie I
thought yeah okay what do you think
what's your reaction to that well my
first thing is frustration
disappointment disbelief you know you
got a you got a young player in hakuna
who's really great for the game and does
things right way and he's swinging hot
that and so to see a ball that goes
right into his ribs towards the wrists
but obviously hitting his elbow I'm
clearly intent and you know when you're
talking about a major league pitcher and
a guy was hot and you're in his worse
and I know he's hot I wanted to focus
feed there was nothing even close to his
feet and a lot of times as people that
have been in a batter's box know that
when you're moving a guy's feet and
dropping him that way that has more
effect than something like that and I
was just very disappointed and
disappointed yeah so what do you think
the punishment should be Dave well
there's there's gonna be in my opinion a
suspension when you're talking about
throwing a baseball with intent that
calls for suspension and you know to
what degree that's up to the
commissioner no I know I know you can't
get in people's heads but
no I'll be I'll ask you bluntly do you
think Mattingly ordered this this Cobra
III don't I don't you know as a manager
and the thing about managing is you
don't ever want to and I can't speak for
Donny but it was he aware of he was
gonna brush him off yes
did he mandated I I don't know and I
would really believe that he idle I
really believe he wouldn't do something
like that because the manager it's
really scary when you mandate something
like that because if something does
happen to a player and cause a serious
injury then that's on you and you don't
ever want to put yourself in that
situation well Dave you know you know I
I had mentioned this the previous hour
Dave Roberts Dodgers manager
I mean Mattingly is not just any manager
he had an eight game homerun streak of
his own in 1987 and we looked it up he
wasn't hit by a pitch a single time so
it's not like something that he
experienced and he went through himself
as a player so you know he knows that
there's a precedence for this sort of
thing and went out and ordered the kid
to hit a cunha so I guess my question
for you is is this an unwritten rule in
baseball I mean is this it is a it is
not IIIi don't think so and I think that
brushing a guy off throwing in and
there's a thing that rich there's a
thing and you know baseball as low as I
do
he'll to be able to throw and to keep a
guy honest you know little instill a
little bit of fear I get it but being
able to throw in and throw on with a
sect is a different thing so if you
can't throw inside and not hit guys like
that then don't throw inside
Dave Roberts here in the Rich Eisen show
and then in your own shop there was a
bench is clearing scenario a couple of
days ago where it seems that we took a
little bit of bait at home plate and
wound up getting ejected have you spoken
to yasiel puig about having I didn't
okay I did I talked to him yesterday and
before the battle for batting practice
and it's one of those things that
obviously it was instigated by Nexon
layette yeah I feel like you said took
the bait and so we all have our pride
our egos and you still have to be a pro
and understand it we need him in the
baseball game so it was good to see
obviously our guys came to his defense
and he's emotional as we all know but
it's a lesson learned that you know that
some sometimes you got to take the high
road mm-hmm and so hey do you think he
heard you
you know what he's emotional Richie you
know that but I definitely think that if
something like this happens in the
future and yoshio with his track record
he's a target and people around the
league they know that and I made it very
clear to him and I don't see this
happening that well I mean look the
history with you and Puig is is you you
you and the Dodgers could have flat-out
cut him a couple years ago instead you
sent him down to triple-a to take some
time in Oklahoma City came back as a a
different player it seems but it yep
there are folks in LA waiting to see
that 2013 Puig come back to the four
here and wondering if there's if there's
on occasion just some coddling to make
sure that that could possibly return
Dave how how would you respond to that
no but I think that if you look back
rich if you look at the since he came
back from a disabled list of each other
and o-p-s of over a thousand and I think
since that point he's you know top three
or four in the National League so is it
that first three weeks of 2000 whatever
whatever he said was 13 no but it's but
over the consistency over the over the
time period it's pretty dang good so how
do you view the next 40 40 days then 40
games Dave how do you how do you how do
you approach it what with a tight race
in that NL West and then certainly the
and a wild card what what's your what's
the approach here the approach is to
focus on each game that that's the way
it's always been and we got the Mariners
setting up to the northwest and this a
team is vying for a playoff berth as
well they're playing good baseball they
got Robby
- no back they got D chord playing good
baseball Nelson Cruz and we're gonna
have our hands full but I think for us
rich it's taking one game at a time okay
so I'm by the way what if I wrote a book
about the unwritten rules and wrote them
out Dave would that be a best-seller do
you think you know what you know what I
would I would buy it rich and that would
burn it that's not the eggs no no it
would be I just want to have it written
out but you know what rich hey there's a
there's a bunch of unwritten laws but
you know what
make a copy and then let me know because
I've been around this game for a long
time and so I guess I don't know yeah I
know I just just I'm glad yeah maybe you
could write you know the foreword for
the book for me Dave because yeah
because there's a manual for us on
unwritten rules that how do you think
that the way the game is supposed to be
played right let me know I would cuz you
know you and I are in lockstep I saw
that I saw that last night this kid
getting hit and just where we're by a 97
mile an hour fastball
so obviously uranium we all know has got
some talent and to me it's just him
basically saying I'm not competing I'm
not gonna compete tonight and that was
so patently disappointing certainly for
for our league that with a young player
like this I'm on the edge of my seat
wanting to see if he was gonna pop
another one out till II don't know
exactly and the thing about this my last
parting shot is you know Bob Gibson's a
person you we all know there's a guy
that threw up in an all the time and
logged close to 3,000 innings and hit a
hundred guys and I saw another article
where all these guys now that we have
currently that have logged a lot lessons
and have hit more guys so even Bob
Gibson who's old school thrown in but
understanding how to throw the baseball
and Tim hoes fear on the hitter and
still commanding that part of the plate
though so there's a difference Dave
always enjoy our chats let's chat down
the line you bet Sammy if Dave Roberts
Dodgers manager that's a big series
dodgers Mariners the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience